各位觀眾大家好,富人藥富人幫,歡迎收看富邦說趨勢,光哥陪你聊趨勢。
我想進入八月份,很高興有這個機會來跟各位分享一下八月份的行情。
七月份因為我們進入論壇,
所以時間上比較排不出來,
那這個地方,
我們七月份的這個錄影的部分就稍微少了一些。
但進入8月份我想行情的反轉
剛好在這個行情的轉折點
我們來做一些分析跟分享
我們今天的這個標題叫做
破解股市的利空虛實
因為在這條AI的這個道路上來看
其實它的基本面沒有變
變的是籌碼
變的是資金
它在這個地方有做些轉換
我今天針對這個所謂的市場上的利空
跟利多來跟各位做一下分享
首先我們來看一下7月29號FOMC會議
我想這部分的解讀到9月份
這一份報告聯準會的利率一直會影響市場
所以我覺得你要很清楚的去解讀聯準會利率到底會怎麼走
結論上來看我們覺得他今年升息的機會應該不高
而且還是有可能比較偏向去降息
等於說最差最差就是不升
就是維持不變
那我們可以看到他這次的部分
有三位委員支持升息一碼
那我想當然他最近的這個通膨
是讓他支持他去升息一碼主要理由
然後他這邊藍色字所提到
市場利率自行上升以提供部分緊縮的效果
顯示市場不再完全依賴聯準會
這是WASH所提到的
我講到這句話
很明顯的表達一個重點
什麼重點
他希望未來打球的人看球打球
不要看裁判打球
等於說在過去一般的投資人
都是看著聯準會的方向來做利率
他希望你用市場上面的一個
所謂的經濟數據
你自己去判斷
而不是你來看我的想法
然後去猜測我的想法
這是他所要表達的
然後他在記者會問答集裡面
我覺得比較精彩
那我這邊有把他的QA的部分
有五個問題
我覺得他的回答部分
我想這個地方已經很明顯的告訴市場
就是市場上正觀察經濟數據而非Fed
然後第二個就是
兩次會議裡面自動緊縮
也提供了這部分的效果
所以我覺得他整體的
這樣的聯準會裡面的內容裡面來看的話
我覺得他有一點點失誠green span
我記得Green Span講了一句話非常經典
就是說當你聽懂我講的話的時候
我想你可能誤解我的意思
換句話說 Green Span不希望市場上去臆測
他在每一次的會議裡面的講話
WASH也是一樣
所以這一塊我覺得WASH未來應該就是兩個方向
A Data Dependent 看Felip曲線
兩個象限 Job Report 跟Inflation 這兩個
第二個Chain Dependent 看趨勢 看AI
AI的生產力是否能夠讓通膨降下來
需要一點時間
但是他相信AI可以帶動整個生產力的增加
所以我想這兩個會是我們在觀察整個
接下來新的聯準會主席
他所要帶給市場上的方向
那第二個部分我們來看一下
市場上的Badge News
他的這種所謂的熊市的這部分的一個利空
到底有些哪些是真的有哪些是假的
我整理一下總共17項
17項裡面有將近一半是真的
有超過一半是假的
等於說你在判斷這樣子的一個過程裡面
可能你會誤殺你的股票
或者有些人是停損真的利空的股票
但是後面可能會慢慢的利空頓化
利空所謂的出盡
我們可以看到資金的部分全部打勾
代表是真正實質的利空
但是會不會真的影響
這個基本上它的影響都是
在瞬間影響完之後
後面慢慢就會淡化
所以在資金的部分
我們坦白說
它這一次是實質的利空
然後再來看一下
政策的部分
我想這一次去幹感
它造成整個這個成交量的
一個下跌之後的自息量完之後
去幹感效果非常好
所以我們把它用一個箭頭向下
然後再來就是在產業競爭的部分
有包括南韓的擴產
長興科技的這部分的一個IPO
其實事實上會影響到
然後這部分Lubinarcha的這個
所謂的基價交付延遲12個月
這也是實質的利空
但是接下來這下面的部分
我們覺得像Case 3啦
或者是Meta這部分的這個
租算力的部分
我們覺得這個都是屬於比較虛的利空
所以這部分實際的影響並不是太大
等於說你現在的三立
算力 存力 電力
基本上存利已經變成是主旋律了
假設你的存利內存
包括DDR5 DDR4
或是LPDDR
或者是我們講的HBM
NAND Flash SSD這四個
其實你看海力士
他所開出來的財報
其實是非常不錯的
只是市場上基站裡面挑鋼筋
讓他在整個財報裡面
就挑出了說
漲價的幅度不如預期
可是你去看
假設漲價幅度不如預期
為什麼會有出現LTA
長期的合約
三星這次長期合約簽了10項裡面有7項的產品
全部綁長期合約
而且它是漲價沒有封頂
跌價有一個Protection 5%
所以基本上這樣子的一個純利
還是持續的一個Positive的情況之下
其實這個AI的敘事才到中間而已
並沒有所謂的泡沫的問題
看完熊市這部分利空的真與假
那我們就來看一下
第三個我們所提到的
賣產值的目前實質
我覺得接下來十月份可能還是會持續
影響到市場上面的這部分的Cash Flow
Margin的部分
我們可以看到四大CSP場
我們從第二季的這部分的Cash Flow
整個四家加起來是正68億
但是你去看彭博
彭博給出來的2026年整體的這部分的
四大CSP廠的Cash Flow會轉成負值 負7億
負7億這樣的一個數字其實
10月份開始轉負的話
等於第三季的這部分的季標它開始轉負的話
我覺得可能就會再一次來做壓力測試
而且這一次是Total加起來是負的
然後你看2027年它是負470億
等於說你這個產業在Hiking的過程裡面
其實你所面臨的這部分的這個Cash Flow
短線上面 我就短暫這種一年到兩年
這部分的一個所謂的負值
我覺得應該是可以承受的
但是你看一下賣產值的
賣產值的其實數字非常非常亮眼
你看2026年
我把這4家NVIDIA AMD Intel加TSMC
把它加起來
現金流的這部分的正值是2580億
明年是高達3777億
分別成長93跟46%
等於說目前看起來很明顯
賣產值的它是賺得波滿盤滿
那CSP場Cash Flow的Margin的部分
其實是轉負的
這個可能就會變成說
我們在這種所謂的上肥下壽
或者是說整個結構上來看
會產生短暫上面的這樣的一個
所謂的財務報表這部分的現金流量
我們講Cash Flow的差異
所以這一塊的一個獲利數字來講
應該沒有太大懸念
臺灣剛好是在這一塊
那美國這個地方我覺得
假設它這邊正值
變成說CSP廠不再做CAPEX投資
那這邊就會降低
那股價跌得更兇
所以我想從這樣子的一個CSP的大廠
Cash Flow這部分的一種所謂的進出來看的話
可能在接下來的兩個季度
都會持續受這樣的一個議題拿出來講
好 那我們拉回來看臺股
臺股走到這個地方
我想在7月份
我們在各的報章媒體裡面都有提出
我們的看法
其實我們覺得說跌破4萬點
其實應該是超跌
那我們從幾個方向上來看
第一個就是說我們從3月份的31705
到48218這樣的一個波段來算
所謂的這個回檔0.382
0.618 0.5的這樣的一個趨勢上來看
從48218到0.382反彈是41911
然後到至15000點
可能就是反彈上來的這樣的一個滿足點
這個是從這一波的趨勢上面往下看
這個我們可以用我們團隊所估計的這樣數字來做參考
然後第二自息量的部分就是從
去年的上半年跟2022年當時的自息量的這樣的一個最低減的幅度
我們去算出來的這個幅度差不多4400億到6300億
但是我們覺得這個是比較是極端值啦
一般來講是用日均量打7折日均量打7折差不多7000億
我們在今年的7月27號假如沒記錯的話
當時我們的新低量是7400億
然後7月30號來到新低價
等於說新低量出現完之後就有一個新低價
新高量出現之後
4個月之後會有一個新高價
所以目前看起來低量應該短線上已經出現了
只是說我們現在把短線上所反彈
就是說下跌的這部分的一個滿足點
39000到39200這個地方
應該是來到一個
我們在計算上面來看一個相對一個支撐點
這個量的部分 我們剛剛用這個月均量的這部分的七折
去算新低量的出現
所以目前看起來在短線上來看
它已經從所謂的這個跌升完之後的反彈
反彈之後變成反轉
我待會做一個所謂的結論來跟各位做分享我的看法
然後第二就是臺積電漲停的這部分的一個次數
臺積電在7月30號漲停板
那天我就開始在思考就是說
臺積電從1994年掛牌到2015年當時的漲停盤是7%
總共漲停 觸及漲停107次
漲停完之後或觸及漲停後面的20天到40天
它的這部分的漲幅
我這個地方是用比較屬於近幾次
但是我剛剛是用比較宏觀是1994年到2015年
如果是開始漲幅是10%的話只有3次
分別是2020年跟2025年
還有今年這一次的7月30號
然後我們可以看一下以後10天後20天
這樣子的3.7 4.6 5.2的
這樣子的一個反彈的幅度上來看
用4319當時7月30號臺積電漲停
對標臺股的這個指數的位置上來看
4.6會到45000點一個月之後
如果是5.2%的話可能到46000點
所以你從這個角度上來看
臺一電的漲停
告訴你它後面的趨勢的變化
等於說它再去測39000點
這個位置的機會相對比較低
所以我覺得從這樣子的一個漲停
可以告訴你在整體的這部分的方向
然後再來我用第二個面向
來跟各位做分享
就是其實一般來講
景氣對這訊號
你看到的數字
可能紅燈綠燈
對你來講沒有感
我把景氣堆積訊號把它連結到股市來看
一般假設景氣堆積訊號
第一顆紅燈亮起的時候
九個月指數見高點
那你就要去看臺灣第一顆紅燈什麼時候亮
2025年12月份第一顆紅燈亮
那往後面推九個月
今年九月份
今年九月份若是以剛剛這樣子的一個60天來看
就是兩個月
這次的這個7月30號 後面兩個月8月9月
跟這個緊急對話訊號是不是很接近
再來看第三個面向 天亮
這個我在之前有跟各位提過
我們再把它整合在一起來看
我們在看到天亮之後的天價應該是3.8個月
我們用4個月來算 4個月來算的話
它這4個月會漲多少 漲17.4%
然後就要去看天亮是什麼時候發生 5月29
5月29當時用盤後成交量加進來的話是1.91兆
若是隻用盤前的話是1.87兆
我們用1.91兆去算這個天量來看的話
3.8月加起來5296789929是不是也是4個月
跟剛剛的景氣對象的話一樣
跟剛剛臺積電漲停板後面往後推的這個時間也是一樣
那它再漲17.4%你把它乘上去超過5萬點
這三個邏輯
我覺得很清楚的
告訴我們富邦說趣的好朋友
其實我們一再一再的提醒你
景氣資金籌碼
基本上景氣沒有變
資金行情沒有變
變的是什麼
籌碼
籌碼這個地方在去槓桿
所以基本上
你就會產生出
這樣子的一個FOMO交易
在這個恐懼的時候
出現了三萬九千多點的
這樣的一個低點
最後我來用結論
我用光哥筆記
我想我平常每天都做筆記
我想記者在跟我做這個互動的時候
有時候我就直接把筆記傳給他看
我今天把筆記來跟各位做一下分享
一般來講 疊完之後有三個步驟
反彈 反彈還會再去徹底
那反彈假設不要去徹底就反轉
反轉就是前波低點要來徹的機會比較不高
但是還是有機會 只是說比較不高
那反彈的話會來再徹一次腳
那目前看起來從反彈變反轉
那什麼時候反轉變回升
等於說是2到3個N字型的上攻
形成一個W底才上去
所以目前要到回升的這個時間點
可能還是需要一點點時間
那現在比較好的是量有出來
好 我們先把它界定現在是反轉
還沒到回升
那計算公式怎麼算
從這一波的高點
6月份48218點
跌到這波低點
7月30號的39384
我們用反彈0.3822到0.618
分別滿足點是42000到44800點左右
今天已經突破了
等於說它已經強勢反彈
382是弱勢反彈
0.5是中性反彈
618是強勢反彈
強勢反彈一出現的時候
代表就是說它已經進入所謂翻轉行情
那什麼時候會到回升
過47000點
等於是48000點下一個高點47000點300多點
過了變回升
這個我們先把它定掉出來
那或者是你用臺積電的這部分的一個算法
臺電高點是2535塊
2535塊你去減掉現在一塊錢漲8點的話
其實你把它減掉現在應該還可以貢獻1000多點
所以第二種算法其實也是告訴我們
跟0.618是很接近的
而且是超過它的
這第一個算法
好那為什麼我們覺得這一波行情
還是持續看好
短線上面這個positive的這個利多因素
第一個我觀察的一個AI的資金溫度計
你記不記得我在之前的幾個影片裡面提到
Bluer Hour 蘭肖這家公司
蘭肖這個蝨目基金其實在過去一年來跌得非常兇喔
可是最近一個月反彈
就代表其實AI的這部分的資金溫度計並沒有太大問題
來第一個 它上漲
第二個 景氣對熱性化 剛剛已經提過了
我就不在這邊贅述
第三個 天亮天價 我剛才提過了
我這邊也不再做這個重複的說明
第四個 臺積電漲停的這部分的次數
我們也是把剛剛把這三點把它加起來一起來看
其實目前看起來 直至9月份有機會去往前波高點來挑戰的
這樣的一個主要的一個positive的利多
第五個 8月15號彩報
我在前面幾次的影片裡面有提到
第一季的這部分的獲利數字1.61兆
第二季QOQ營收成長12%
第一季的butternight11.22%
用第一季的butternight乘以第二季的營收
其實他是有機會挑戰1.88兆
上半年3.5兆
一般過去上下半年是4比6
我用1比1來比的話
其實今年就會挑戰7兆的水準
非常非常棒 這個數字我覺得很好
等於說接下來的每個月的10號
他公佈上個月的營收
回歸基本面
絕對是我們臺灣股市裡面的一個利多
這是一個財報部分的效應
第六個是外資
外資為什麼空單這麼多
我覺得他在做一個動作
Buy Alpha Sell Beta
什麼叫Buy Alpha
Buy Alpha就是他買主動式ETF
你去看一下他有買一檔主動式ETF
他買了50多萬張
他買了50多萬張的這個主動式ETF
基本上他是看好整個AI的趨勢喔
然後他放空什麼 放空期貨
放空期貨我把它算了一下
他放空期貨7月17號轉倉的當時的成本
43,600點
然後那時候指數上上下下
46000 42000
所以他平均成本應該44000
所以現在只要指數過44000
8月的第三個禮拜三
他要棋子結算
他勢必被尬到
所以他基本上我覺得他到底是避險還是實際看空
你從他by alpha sell beta這樣角度來看
他沒有看空臺股
而且各位富邦數據草片要注意到
投信是做多臺子期89000口
等於說投信做了
跟外資放空的口數
其實是一樣的
所以你在這個地方
就會形成一個多空對決
所以我從這張表
我的筆記裡面
我想就是短線上
我先跟各位講說
現在是進入所謂的反轉區
那我們這個地方就是
折時這個地方
已經跟各位做分享了
再來就是折股
就是你可能要持續追蹤
我們富邦投顧的裡面的報告
提供給你們折時跟折股
我覺得你才有辦法在這一場的這個
所謂的這個股市裡面的一個變化裡面
獲得比較好的一個利潤
我想經過我剛剛的這樣的一個結論
跟光哥筆記的這樣說明
我想非常清楚
8月份的操作的這樣一個邏輯
那最後我希望我們富邦說去世好朋友
能夠加入我們富邦投顧的會員
掃一下我們螢幕上的QR code
加入我們富邦投顧的會員
並且長期支持我們富邦證券的YT的節目
按讚訂閱加分享
希望各位富當過去的好朋友支持
謝謝